les vents dans la brume de l'Est arrivent comme si
quelque chose se préparait à commencer
mesdames et messieurs, nous commençons
notre descente vers Los Angeles en présentant
le créateur de notre bien-aimée Mary Poppins,
jamais seulement Mary maintenant, quand est-ce que mr.  Disney
tu dois m'appeler beaucoup d'idées le
tableau de réponse n'est pas un mot nous l'
avons bien inventé défaire la maison du bébé
ne ressemble pas à ça tout est faux
je ne la transformerai pas en l'un de vos
dessins animés idiots
dit le  femme qui a envoyé une nounou volante
avec un parapluie parlant pour sauver les
enfants en utilisant bébé Poppins ne
sauve pas deux enfants
mr.  Travers qu'est-ce qui me manque ici Mary
Poppins et les banques sont leur famille pour
moi Mary Poppins était une vraie personne donc
ce ne sont pas les enfants qu'elle vient dire
c'est leur père c'est ton père
tu ne sais pas ce qu'elle signifie pour moi je
vais décevoir
tu ne veux pas finir l'histoire